[Music]
foreign
and Nicola Peltz Beckham and she jokes
that we can all just go ahead and call
them a throuple oh my goodness Selena
kicked off 2023 by going on vacay with
the newlyweds and some friends and
documented the whole thing on Instagram
including these cozy moments with the
couple riding alongside it quote fine
call us a throuple forever plus one and
Nicola she doubled down on all that
swooping into the comments to affirm
Selena speaking straight backs it's
really cool and the love is mutual
Nicholas shared her own snaps from the
getaway gushing over her friend in the
caption quote love you so much
it's enjoying my life with the people
that I love in fact they love each other
so much that they even partied in
matching outfits that Selena and Nicola
rocking silver sparkling Valentino mini
dresses on New Year's Eve Nicola posted
these pics of the tags embroidered with
their names and cell she thanked the
designer for the dresses that she said
made her feel like a fairy I love it and
get this the besties cemented their bond
by getting matching angel tattoos I'm in
a really happy place but before joining
Selena for the new year Nicola and
Brooklyn celebrated their first
Christmas as a married couple the two
tied the knot in Florida in April after
nearly three years together and when ET
chatted with Nicola in November she
couldn't help but Swoon over her man
Brooklyn's truly like my best friend so
we've been together three years and I
feel like I'm living with my best friend
and also like the love of my life so
it's been nice and all all that Echoes
what Brooklyn told ET just a few months
earlier one of the pop culture moments
of 2022 was your unbelievable wedding
congratulations does it feel different
um it does feel different you know like
I think like you know I married my best
mate and it's the best feeling in the
world and you know it's just me and her
it's absolutely the best and yeah I love
it and Brooklyn he's ready to expand the
fan I've always wanted to be a young Dad
it's like been my dream yeah and you
know as I said before I found my best
mate you know and I would love to I
would love to have a family soon but
whenever my wife is ready so yeah a big
family like yours I hope so I hope so I
I could have like 10. he tells you this
all the time we really do want a big
family we want to have some of our own
kids and then we really want to adopt
kids too there's no doubt these two will
make awesome parents one day but in the
meantime we'll just be here standing
Brooklyn Nicola and Celine giving us as
cell puts it thruple goals
[Music]